من ايامه لسه هو العنوان الابرز والاول في
الاخبار والمواقع والمنصات وحقيقه كميه
الفريدز للواحد قريها عن الموضوع الايام
الماضيه على تويتر غير طبيعيه طبعا بتكلم
عن خبر افلاس بنك سيليكون فالي واللي ممكن
جدا نسميه وحش افلاس بنك
فاللي فعليا صار او جالس يصير على المنصات
ما فينا نسميه الا حاله من الرعب والهلع
هذا من ناحيه الافراد والمختصين ومن ناحيه
الحكومات والدول الدنيا كمان مقلوبه
تصريحات وتطمينات وتدخلات وفعليا بنك ما
كنا سمعنا فيه من قبل على الاقل يعني احنا
كناس مو مختصه في الاقتصاد فجاه صرنا نشوف
رئيس اكبر دوله في العالم طالع بكلمه خاصه
عنه وحكومات بريطانيا والمانيا وغيرها
بتتكلم عنه واجراءات وحسابات وسيل من
الاخبار فعليا احنا من كم يوم تناولنا
معكم بالموضوع وبسطناه على قد ما نقدر
يعني لنا وللمشاهد يعني وشرحنا ازمه البنك
الحاليه لكن اليوم لسه في تساؤلات خاصه
وان الموضوع جالس يتطور اولا في تضارب او
خناجات اونلاين بين كثير ناس هذا بنك
عملاق او لا الناس تقول ايه ناس تقول لا
ثانيا ليه كل هذه الدوله او ياكل هذه
الدول تحديدا متدخله في الموضوع وماخذ هذه
الابعاد السياسيه هل المفروض اللي بيصير
حاليا هذه يخوفنا احنا كافراد عاديين يعني
اللي هم لا مستثمرين ولا شيء ثالثا وقبل
كل هذا انا كشخص عادي مو مستثمر حاطط
فلوسي المتواضعه في بنك كيف اضمن امانها
كيف اضمن انه البنك بيستثمرها صح وما رح
يصير لها شيء بعد الاشياء اللي احنا
نسمعها رح تساعدنا في الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله زميلتنا في قسم الاقتصاد لارا
حبيب اهلا فيك معانا يا لارا منوره
بالاحمر لون غير محبب عندكم
الاسود فعلا طيب البنك يعني هو هذا
كبير اللي عامل الضجه دي كلها
هو بانك بدك تعتبريه هذا بنك ستارز شركات
الناشئه بقى كل الشركات الناشئه وقتها
تجمع كثير مصاري من الفانز منسميهم اللي
بيدعموا شركات الناشئه بتروح بتحط
هالاموال
بمصرفي بقى بدك تشوفي انه هو
معين من تركيز من نوع معين من العملاء
لذلك صار في داعر هن صاروا يخبروا بعضهم
انه هذا المصرف عنده بعض المشاكل صار في
دار ركضوا تيسحبوا اموالهم من هذا المصرف
علما انه اي وديعه فوق ال 250 الف دولار
هي غير مضمونه من الجهات التنظيميه في
الولايات المتحده في كثير من هول الشركات
كان عندهم ودائع اكثر بكثير يعني في شركات
مثلا سبوتيفاي كان عندها وديعه هونيك
شركات تكنولوجيا معروفه عندها لانه هذا
بقدم خدمات مصرفيه البنوك العاديه بنوك
العاديه ما بتقدمها لهيك صار في دعار ولا
هيك صار فيه سحوبات كبيره امس شفنا كميه
بيانات كبيره يعني طلع الرئيس بايدن في
خطاب شفنا الحكومه
البريطانيه الحكومه الالمانيه شفنا بعدين
ظهورك على الهواء فتحت الاسواق الامريكيه
وتغطيه كل الموضوع وشفنا الانخفاض اللي
كان جالس بيصير ليش
حكومات كبيره في هذا الموضوع لانه دائما
بخافوا انه نحن نرجع عم نعيش ازمه ماليه
عالميه يلي هي اصلا بلشت عام 2008 مع فشل
عده بنوك في الولايات المتحده على راسها
بير ستارز ومن بعدها لمن برادرز دائما في
خوف انه يصير في عدوى على مصارف اخرى
يفشل مصرف هذا مش بس بيفشل المصرف لحاله
يعني زبائن عملاء المصرف ما عندهم اكسس
للودائع تبعهم يقدروا يدفعوا اجور موظفين
بقى هيدا بياثر على كذا
ومش بس هيك في بنوك اخرى او في حتى مؤسسات
اخرى واضحه اموال لها او منكشفه على هذا
المصرفة بمليون
مكشوف ممكن
او مثلا عندها مثلا يعني شركات ستارز حتى
بالمنطقه نحن قبلنا عدد منهم هم مستثمرين
بشركات تكنولوجيا ستارتبس عنده هول
الشركات عند ودائعها بهذا المصرف فهن
منكشفين بطريقه غير مباشره يعني ما عندهم
يعني معرضين للخطر طيب
شو صار مبارح مبارح صار يخافوا انه بنوك
اخرى تكون منكشفه على هذا المصرف بطريقه
معينه ام بطريقه غير عريانه
ابدا
ههه هلا
برضه طلعت حتى في المنطقه عندنا وانتم
قابلتوا بعض الاشخاص منا فانه الموضوع
عشان كده اخذ صعيد عالمي يعني
لانه مثل ما حكينا اذا عندك وديعه فوق ال
250 الف دولار سعره يخافوا انه لا لازم
انا قيمه بعدين
لهيك اضطر السلطات انه تقول بالمصارف يلي
نهارين نحن رح نضمن كل الودائع بغض النظر
على قيمتها وهيك هادئه الاسواق واليوم
شفنا انه الاسواق هديه بلا عم بتسجل
ارتفاع يعني مثل كانه هلا من الممكن
الحديث بس مثل كانه انه الازمه تراجعت
بشكل
خطر على مصاريف اخرى خاصه المصاريف
الصغيره يعني في ترند عم بنشوفه بالولايات
المتحده عم بيروح عمل المصارف الصغيره
يسحبوا اموالهم ويحطوها بالمصارف لانه هي
اقل خطوره خايفين هذا اللي كنت بدي اسالك
عنه انه نحن كافراد لما لانه شايفك كتير
ناس جالسين بيقولوا انه البنك اخطا في
استثماراته فالنتيجه كانت هذا الفشل وهذا
الافلاس يعني
احنا حاطين فيها فلوسنا تخطئ في
استثماراتها
رقبيه لهيك في جهات رقبيه في شروط صارمه
على ضمنيني بالله يعني او حتى ليش عم نفرق
بالولايات المتحده بين البنوك الاصغر
والبنوك الاكبر بعد الازمه الماليه
العالميه يلي كان سببها انه البنوك عملت
استثمارات باصول سميناها توكسيك اصول منا
منيحه ابدا وهي قديت سامه هي ادت الى هذه
الازمه الماليه العالميه بعد بكم سنه صار
في قانون بالولايات المتحده اسمه انون دوت
فرانك هو اللي بينظم عمل البنوك وهو يلي
بيدع شروط شو هي نوعيه الاصول يلي فيها
تحملها هذه البنوك بالعام
بسبب لوبينغ من قبل البنوك الاصغر قالوا
لهم انتم ما فيكم تطبقوا علينا هذه الشروط
بالتالي خففوا شروط الرقابه على البنوك
الاصغر وعم بحكي البنوك الاصغر يعني قيمه
اصولها اقل من 250 مليار دولار ما زالت
بنوك كبيره ولكن بين معيار الولايات
المتحده لذلك
قدرنا انه نشوف هل المشكله بشكل مفاجئ
بدون هذا البنك يكون عنده
رقابه اكثر على الخسائر اللي مني بها علما
مره اخرى منذكر انه المشكله كانت انه اضطر
يبيع اصول
يقدر يوفي طلبات السريعه للودائع لانه في
كثير عالم راح وسحب سحبوا الودائع بس
هالاصول اللي باعها هيدي اصول جيده جدا
وهي اصول من المفترض انه تكون اصول بدون
مخاطر يعني سندات تفاصيل
الفجعه بس والذعر وال انهيار
والعواجل وهذا كله على العموم انت طبعا
حتحكي في التفاصيل هذه اكثر في نشره
الاقتصاد نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كانت معنا زميلتنا في قسم الاقتصاد لارا
حبيبي اعتقد هذه يمكن اغرب مره تطلعي فيها
صح ههه المنكشفه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]